after being free for two years a Florida
man is headed back to prison for murder
he says he did not commit you'll recall
65 year old Crosley green surrendered to
the Florida Department of Corrections on
Monday after losing his final bid to
remain at home with his family earlier
this month the State of Florida ordered
green to return to prison after the U.S
Supreme Court declined to hear his
appeal green spent 32 years in prison
for a murder that he says he did not
commit including 19 on death row a
federal judge overturned his conviction
back in 2018 ruling that Green's right
to a fair trial had been violated an
appeals court then reversed that ruling
Green's attorneys are seeking either
clemency from Florida's governor or
parole from the state our Moriarty is
going to have a lot more on this case on
48 hours